[Music]
on this tuesday night wildfires
displacing people and polluting the air
a state of emergency declared in bc as
fast-moving flames force hundreds to
leave everything
behind we have reached a critical point
getting evacuation plan ready
and the plumes of smoke reducing air
quality across big parts of the country
what emails reveal about the kovid 19
emergency plan
at an ontario care home where dozens of
residents died
a global news investigation don't
go americans told to avoid the uk as
coveted cases there
spike and billionaires
space race what's the point of jeff
bezos's 11-minute rocket ride
and should the rich focus instead on
helping planet earth
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
this is the reality of what crews on the
front lines in bc are facing this video
was taken by firefighters in the heart
of bc's wine country
in just a few hours last night a
fast-moving wildfire
exploded hundreds of properties have
been evacuated
the mayor of one okanagan town is urging
vacationers to pack up
and go home good evening and thanks for
joining us we are tracking a number of
fires from bc to ontario
tonight we begin though in bc where the
situation is volatile
the weather forecast worrying and now
the province has declared a state of
emergency it takes effect
at midnight tonight this will address
the potential
for a mass evacuation scenario and
provide our government with the means to
secure the accommodation spaces
necessary
to support evacuees
here's the big picture across bc there
are more than 290
active fires now 87 are out of control
37 are considered wildfires of no
meaning
they pose a potential threat to public
safety
this is what it looks like right now in
bc's south okanagan where one of the
most concerning fires is burning
this is the view from soyuz the smoke
you see is from the aggressive
inca meep creek fire yesterday it was
estimated at 300 hectares
now it's grown to 2 000 hectares
global's claudia van emerick is in soyuz
tonight claudia set the scene for us
donna thank you this fire is an
aggressive one it is a fast-moving one
you can see
behind me a massive plume of smoke
there's visible flame on the hillside
and the winds are pushing this fire in a
southerly
direction towards the northern part of
osuyus now
there are evacuation alerts and orders
in place for hundreds of properties
between the towns of oliver and soyuz
about 250 properties on
order 150 on alert and there are local
states of emergencies
issued by multiple local governments
here
now a major evacuation effort that took
place overnight and early this morning
was across a soyuz lake at the spirit
ridge resort which is very popular
and usually filled to capacity during
the summer months
so vacationers there were told to flee
overnight
as were tourists in the adjacent
campground
the inca meep campground affecting about
a thousand tourists
we got knocks on the door at about five
o'clock this morning that you know the
fire department was there
and they were telling us to just gather
our things as quickly as we could and
start making our way out of the
park we're just done pins and needles
and we're not even in
at the end of july i'm sure happy to see
the sports services
the fire uh department's been out there
bc wild
services the planes are flying i mean
everybody's putting everything they can
into stopping this fire
controlling it now the mayor of
is strongly urging the tourists that are
here to simply
pack up and go home because not only is
this fire inching closer to town but
there is no room to house all the
vacationers now as for this fire fight
the bc wildfire service is throwing in
extra resources to fight it from the
ground
and from the air but at this point donna
it is still
very much out of control deeply worrying
situation claudia
van emerick in a soyuz specie thanks
bc isn't the only province dealing with
an early and aggressive wildfire season
this is the picture across the country
today the red dots are fires burning out
of control
dozens of them are in saskatchewan that
province has recorded more than 420
fires so far this year
that is roughly double the five-year
average for this time of
214. ontario also has had higher than
average fires 735
so far last year there were 421
by mid july all that smoke is having a
major impact on air quality far from
where the fires are burning
this forecast map from fire smoke canada
shows how the smoke is spreading across
large parts of canada
and into the u.s communities from bc to
new brunswick are now
under air quality alerts this is what it
looked like
in toronto today once again that city
was ranked one of the worst in the world
for air quality eric sorenson explains
what the air quality alerts mean and why
we can expect more of them because of
the changing climate
first it was the wildfires now it's the
smoke with a boost from canada's
prevailing winds
smoky air is spreading from western
canada all the way to new brunswick
in some bc communities smoke is making
it harder to fight the wildfires
in manitoba environment canada has
issued an air quality advisory for much
of the province
including winnipeg the hazy air is now
being inhaled by millions of canadians
as it wafts over large cities like
calgary it bothers the
sinuses a little bit because there's so
much
smoke in the air winds from northwestern
ontario have spread smoke more than a
thousand kilometers south into the
country's largest urban area
toronto people in northwestern ontario
have to live with this
all the time because they are right in
the middle of fire season
it seems so far away for southern
ontario as it
you know they don't affect us but they
do for most of this summer downtown
toronto's air quality health index
registered as
low risk but last evening for about
three hours
it was high risk bordering on very high
risk this afternoon
it is back to moderate risk the concern
going forward
is whether there will be increasingly
more days like this in the future
scientists say a big city like toronto
is a large emission source for air
pollutants at any time
wildfire smoke only makes it worse
wildfires are
definitely a dominant contributor to the
poor air quality we're seeing throughout
the country
studies over canada have shown that with
climate change we expect
the potential for uncontrollable fires
doubling
in the areas that we're seeing fires
currently those with respiratory
conditions are at risk when air quality
is bad
and doctors expect the risk to rise as
the climate warms and wildfires occur
more often
we see an immediate uptick in asthma
exacerbations exacerbations of
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and we also see an increase
in other inflammatory conditions so
heart attacks strokes
we also know that what we're seeing
today is not the new normal
we know that things are just getting
worse in southern ontario
rain in the forecast should offer some
relief but in large swaths of western
and northern canada
the wildfire season and the smoke it
brings is far from over
erik sorensen global news toronto
newly obtained emails from toronto
public health suggest a long-term care
home which had the deadliest kovid 19
outbreak in ontario
ignored advice that could have helped
save lives more than 300 residents and
staff at tender care living center
tested positive for covid
81 residents died tonight carolyn jarvis
has the details of the advice
that was not followed for months tender
care living center had an
outbreak plan in place use a vacant wing
of its fourth floor
to isolate residents who tested positive
for coveted 19
but when coveted struck on december 4th
the fourth floor
wasn't used internal emails from toronto
public health obtained by global news
suggest tender care changed course only
days into the outbreak
saying the fourth floor was not
appropriate for a variety of reasons
such as no call bells and no curtains
according to the emails written in april
toronto public health and scarborough
health network suggested a seemingly
simple solution
baby monitors for no call bells and room
dividers for the lack of curtains
but toronto public health wrote these
suggestions were not agreed upon by the
facility
the fact that tender care had a fourth
floor wing that was left vacant
and not utilized and there was no
emergency plan for how to handle this
crisis when they had the first wave to
figure it out
and come up with said plan is completely
inexcusable and entirely unforgivable
neither tender care nor its management
company extendicare would answer
questions about the toronto public
health emails that say the home rejected
advice to use baby monitors and room
dividers
extendicare says the region was
overwhelmed with covet cases
and there were no staffing resources
available to open the unit
that response isn't enough for those who
lost their loved ones at tender care
like reed zhao whose grandmother died of
kovid
i feel anger and frustrated of course
it's not only the the lack of
arrangement for the fourth floor missing
baby monitors
and at the height of the outbreak they
should have caught in
support from the red cross from the
canadian
armed forces there are things they could
do the ontario government has
apologized for the impact of the
pandemic on long-term care homes
and says new legislation is coming this
fall
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
the covid concerns overshadowing the
olympics coming up tokyo 2020 organizers
watch the rising case numbers and say
it's
still possible to call things off
the tokyo olympics officially kick off
with the opening ceremonies on friday
but there will be no cheering crowds
few in japan are celebrating and it's
still possible
events could be canceled mike armstrong
reports
these were supposed to be the recovery
olympics
when the games were awarded to japan the
country was still reeling from the 2011
tsunami
now instead of excitement in bustling
streets
kovit has many questioning if the game
should be happening
at all this man says there's no recovery
it feels like the olympics themselves
aren't in the mood for the olympics
there is a rigid testing program in
place for athletes and delegations
as of tuesday the ioc says 67 people
accredited for the games
have tested positive for kovid 19 when
the game's ceo was asked tuesday if they
could still be canceled
and this could he said he couldn't
predict what's going to happen to the
number of cases but that there would be
discussions
if there's a spike now for the athletes
these games
aren't what they're used to the social
aspect is taking a hit
these will be canadian swimmer yuri
kissel's second olympics
it's definitely a little different for
sure you can't like run up to like
friends and stuff you see on other teams
and give them a hug
it didn't take us by surprise canadian
softball pitcher lauren regula is
competing in her third games
she says the team's tested daily and
that there are restrictions that keep
them to their bubble
we're sticking to ourselves and you know
we eat in the same place
some of the restrictions are creating
frustrations for the media
just about all they can see if tokyo is
in what's billed as an
out of the bubble bus trip well it's
good to have
something out of the bubble these trips
are another thing
some are using to argue the olympic
bubble is broken
tokyo is officially under a state of
emergency and residents are being told
to stay at home
yet every day japanese media covers
cases of visitors
interacting with locals of course they
are supposed to be within the bubble
but you know it's not working well
the public's confidence in these games
is suffering a poll this week found
55 percent of the country is against
holding these olympics mike armstrong
global news
the u.s state department and centers for
disease control have issued a warning to
americans about the uk
the u.s has raised the warning to the
highest level level four telling
americans to
avoid travel to the united kingdom
because there is a very high level of
covid19 there
the cdc says if you must travel to the
uk make sure you are
fully vaccinated but it warns there is
still the potential
to get sick in india the number of
people who have died from covid19
may be nearly 10 times higher than the
official death toll
a new study by the u.s based center for
global development
estimates excess deaths that's the gap
between those recorded and those that
would have been expected
is between 3 and 4.7
million officially india is reporting
more than 414 000 people died from coven
it's believed overwhelmed hospitals may
have missed recording many deaths
in the u.s there was a fiery exchange
today between dr
anthony fauci and republican senator
rand paul
fauci the top infectious disease expert
in the u.s
denied he lied to congress about u.s
funding
what's called gain of function research
at the wuhan
virology lab in china research ran paul
claims
increased the transmissibility of
viruses and resulted in the deaths of
millions of people
this was fauci's reaction
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about
quite frankly and i want to say that
officially
and you are implying that what we did
was responsible for the deaths of
individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying here senator
it is you
i had one on one with prime minister
justin trudeau what he says about
accountability for indigenous children
harmed by the residential school system
it's likely there will be a federal
election soon and we now know one
prominent person who won't be running
mark carney the former governor of the
bank of england and the bank of canada
told the canadian press he is not going
to run there was much speculation carney
would turn to politics but he says he's
committed to helping organize the
private financial sector ahead of
november's
u.n climate conference he says he
doesn't rule out running at some point
in the future and says he supports prime
minister justin trudeau
far nasser sat down with trudeau to talk
about election planning
while the country faces a reckoning over
residential schools
you've been traveling quite a bit
recently a lot of people say you're
campaigning
this is what summer looks like for a
politician to get out there and meet
with people
especially after a pandemic where we've
been working really hard to support
people to have people's backs through
the pandemic and now people are
expecting us to be part of building back
better
so are you not meeting with advisors
talking about an election calling your
staff back from
the minority government there's always
uh there's always times where we have to
be ready for whatever comes but
we're focused on continuing to deliver
for canadians every step of the way
i want to focus right now on
islamophobia the national council of
canadian muslims says since the london
terror attack there has been a violent
incident against a muslim
every day why canada why do you think
that's happening here
we are seeing a rise of hatred a rise of
intolerance
fed in some places by populism and by
politics of division what about policy
though prime minister i mean you
represent the writing of papano it's
such a diverse writing
but there are people in your writing who
feel like you're not standing up to that
for them when it comes to
bill 21 do you honestly feel like you're
doing the best
in your power to stand up for those
people okay you know first of all let me
be very clear
okay i am opposed to that law and
everybody in papua new
most people across the country know uh
that i am in total disagreement with
bill 21
uh i don't think it's for any government
particularly in a country that values
rights and liberties to dictate to a
woman what she can and cannot wear i
think that's just
wrong however we have a justice system
that is set up
so that individuals can take their
governments to court
do you think it's racist i think it is
uh i think it's the wrong thing to be
doing
i do not think it goes in the right
direction i want to move on to
residential schools because this has
been a reckoning as you know
across canada but you know the truth and
reconciliation commission
spent uh five years getting testimony
from these survivors and now we have
these possible
crime scenes in multiple provinces yet
virtually no one has been held
accountable for what's happening you
said
and now we have these crime scenes no
those crime scenes have been there for
generations and we've known about them
so generations and indigenous peoples
have known about them for generations
what about accountability prime minister
what about the criminal charges there's
nobody's being charged would you like to
see that would you like to see criminal
accountability
what i want to see is secondary
to what the communities need yes
absolutely i will support anything that
families need to move forward because
you have to remember
that even as uh indigenous
kids were being told that they had no
worth they had no value in those
residential schools
and every other school in canada kids
were being told non-indigenous kids were
being told
that indigenous communities had no worth
had no value
so reconciliation isn't just about
indigenous people and the government
right
it's about all of us and we all have a
role to play
okay prime minister thank you so much
for your time pleasure
you can watch pharah's full interview
with the prime minister on our website
globalnews.ca globalnational
next the woman who waited decades to
defy gravity
for the second time this month a
multi-billionaire has made it to the
edge of space in his
rocket amazon founder jeff bezos flew
107 kilometers above the earth's surface
and lived to tell the tale
and he brought three people with them
including 82 year old wally funk
an accomplished pilot she's one of 13
women who thanks to private funding
volunteered to undergo astronaut
training in the 1960s
she excelled at it but the training was
cancelled and the women were excluded
from nasa's space program
funk has waited six decades for this
moment
i've been waiting a long time to finally
get it up there
and i've done a lot of astronaut
training through the world
and i could always beat the guys on what
they were doing because i was always
stronger and i've always done everything
on my own it was wonderful i want to go
again
fast jackson prosco looks at
billionaires in their rockets and
whether the money could be better spent
here on earth
this might be the most important
delivery jeff bezos has ever completed
a gentle drop-off in the texas desert
after a ride to the edge of space
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically exceeded
52 years to the day after humans first
walked on the moon
blue origin's new shepard rocket roared
into the sky
making history by carrying both the
oldest and youngest passengers into the
record books
18 year old oliver damon of the
netherlands and 82 year old wally funk
finally getting her glimpse of space up
close
i i loved every minute of it i just wish
it a little longer
all told the crew experienced about four
minutes of weightlessness
while the world's richest man became the
latest billionaire to stake a claim to
space
joining the ranks of richard branson and
elon musk
i want to thank every
amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this bezos
sees space
tourism as a path to space exploration
it's also a lucrative business catering
to the ultra wealthy
the company claims to have sold 100
million dollars worth of tickets for
future launches
at an undisclosed price per seat the
price is going to be set by the market
demand
so right now the only data point we have
is that somebody was willing to pay 28
million dollars
for the first blue origin ticket for
that price a lucky few can now see the
world the way only a few hundred people
ever have
a prospective past astronauts have
described as life-changing
when you go into space and see how
fragile it is you'll want to take care
of it even more
like his fellow space billionaires bezos
has
big dreams to one day explore the moon
and beyond
back on planet earth these baby steps
are for now
all about the business of space tourism
one small step
for those who can afford it jackson
prosko global news
washington
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the sunset at remick rapids
park
in ottawa thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you